I like to think that ultimate biology
ultimate biology is going to emerge
within the next several decades and it's
going to be in three domains one has
already begun and that is the creation
of artificial life and scientists have
just very recently put together from
chemicals off the shelf of a genome that
is of the entire DNA of a bacterium
inserted it into a bacterial shell and
Kree and created a functioning
reproducing bacterium that white
chemicals off-the-shelf
an organism a very simple organism
organism now this is momentous because
it means that week as we develop this
technology we're going to eventually be
able to produce multicellular organisms
and and the new kinds of species will
have that capacity and it's going to
raise all kinds of questions certainly
opportunities and among the
opportunities that it will present if we
don't let the excesses and the deviation
and auxilary consequences unforeseen
overwhelm us is that we're going to be
able to produce improvements in the
productivity of our food plants and of
organisms are vital for the maintenance
of human dominated environments I mean I
say that in that way because I also
believe it's going to be absolutely
necessary for the welfare of planet
Earth that we leave a large part of the
planet to the eight million other
species that occupies earth with us
because that's the shield that already
is in place to which we are exquisitely
well adapted
that's call that creation of life is
called synthetic biology and market well
synthetic biology is just taking off and
it means it's going to have impact in a
lot of ways and it will segue in its
consequences and what it reveals about
the nature of life and you manage
yourself as it comes in to the era of
artificial intelligence and robotics in
in a big way there is ongoing at the
present time I know I've just met with a
number of them a something of a
controversy between the artificial
intelligence and humanoid robotics
creators like a controversy over whether
we're going to duplicate the brain
digitally most things that that can be
done you know that we that's not exactly
how neurons really work they work on
mass in creating waves of activities
that then trigger other ways hormonal
release and so on but against that
viewpoint also exist of the analog
robotic thinkers who believe the human
brain is just so thoroughly analog it's
and that it doesn't really work
digitally but it works by activation of
masses of neurons layers low SCI and
WebWork that passes varying degrees are
subjectively felt by others through
other pathways and centers until finally
they reach decision points mostly in the
subconscious brain no we have coming
ahead in the development of these
various fields the capacity one to
immensely alter once we know the the
full genomes and artificial intelligence
synthetic biology is an event profoundly
alter food plants almost create new ones
that will substantially increase the per
capita food supply of the world with
enormous consequences and then on the
other hand we have the capacity in time
of producing robots that can think like
humans and on much lower wattage than
our prison robots of the human body and
the human brain works incidentally
that's something like 1,000 energy input
of an advanced robot so that's another
direction it's going to be taken and
what's running through your mind if
you're listening to me or seeing me now
is oh if we keep on going can the robots
with their artificial
organisms around them and their their
intelligence and ability to make
decision then replace us no way that's
great for Hollywood but we're since
we're going to be approaching robot
capacity and genome modification you
know another organism and then even
ourselves we can change our own genome
to some respect where we're going to see
the risk of of giving control to any
other intelligent agent and make sure
that it's just not going to happen
you